this is a pressure pack night for a lot
of you and the nominees are sitting in
the audience and people are wondering
what are they thinking now I have had
this gift since I first started hosting
the show that I can look in anyone's
eyes and I know exactly what they're
thinking so watch the screen and I'll
tell you what what's on their minds
this better not go too late I have six
parent-teacher conferences in the
morning
Billy Jelena I love the sound of that
for 20 days and 20 nights the emperor
penguin will march to a place so extreme
it supports no other life
Andy Dufresne was my friend
Billy didn't tell me that kiss was being
filmed